the main reason why Jada pinkett-smith
is with it this morning we're so excited
she is a creator chances are you've seen
it it's mega hit ginormous red tabletalk
streaming on Facebook watch with her
daughter Willow favorite daughter Willow
her mother Adrienne banfill Norris there
she is
they have raw and raw is a word
conversations on provocative issues
ranging from marriage to mental health
well she does that but she also sticks
her other jobs she's returning to the
big screen and the action movie Angel
has fallen with Gerard Butler Pinkett
Smith portrays an FBI agent
investigating an assassination attempt
on the president played by Morgan
Freeman Butler plays a Secret Service
agent who was wrongfully accused you're
in st. Matthews hospital you remember
how you got you it's the last thing you
remember
you know Mike is very important you tell
me the last thing you remember
present where's the president where is
he is he okay
how's it in Trumbull is in a coma and
your whole team is dead except you tell
me how that happened
she's about to Jack him up I was
thinking this about you Jade you don't
know how to play wimpy wussy girls all
your characters seem to be really badass
kind of women is that what you're drawn
to I am feel like one of those women I
do feel like one of those women but I am
trying to find the more vulnerable side
of myself I'm so where is she I know I
mean when you sit at the red table
occasional yeah but I am definitely I
want to challenge myself with with
finding roles on the silver screen that
have a little bit more vulnerability for
sure why did this one appeal to you well
you know I got to taste your raw Butler
around yeah good and it was out of the
country and I just really loved where
was it we shot in London okay yeah and
so and just to have the opportunity to
work with Morgan Freeman as well and I
really loved the director of this movie
and it's a fun movie I love the series
my bonus entree is a huge like mom you
got to do this movie yeah how big apart
does that play and making a decision
influenced because you know you want
your kids to be excited so you know he
was really he's a big fan of this
particular franchise well I think it's
gonna do very well for you Jada
pinkett-smith but will it do as well as
a read Table Talk that would be hard I
was so obsessed with this show how did
it come about because you've got the
three-generation yeah guys talk about
everything it works at all yeah I think
that I did it many years ago and I think
well I was about 11 for mother's day
because I was like wow you know for us
to all sit around as three generations
of women to talk about different
experiences that we've had thus far from
Mother's Day and there were things that
willow didn't know about my mother and I
you know and I did you learn stuff about
Willow do you learned a lot about willow
we always learn a lot about will always
has my jaw drop at the table this is not
just the share in care hour though I
mean for viewers who have not seen the
show every topic that you may not want
to talk about with your daughter and
your other present is talked about right
only that's the whole point which is why
it's called you know the read table do
you talk about this stuff before you
actually have the conversation do you
sort of pre-interview each other or you
just dive in we just dive in it really
does look like it's totally unscripted
ooh we have a clip from the read Table
Talk
I meant to ask this before we do okay
because it looks like it's totally
unstated appear yes my hand with a news
[Laughter]
in other room and I was like I said Jada
this is the deal I grew up in a
household where I watched my father
punch my mother in the face and I will
not create a house space and interaction
with a person where there's profanity
and violence if you have to talk to me
like that we can't be together Wow yeah
you all are very very candid you know
will was a guest but he's not a regular
guest on the show but you feel very open
talking about all the things all aspects
of your life
is there anything off limits for you no
I mean there hasn't been something
that's come up thus far I mean I do
believe there's a difference between
being open and private what do you mean
what's the line I mean but see that's
subjective yeah yes you know it depends
on what the topic is you know but I do
know that in my own personal life women
specifically have had the courage to be
completely and raw like honest in a very
raw way have really saved me from making
some big mistakes in my life what I like
about it it's not celebrity driven it's
really topic true absolutely celebrities
it's great you have them but your and
generationally is
yes do this we stole this from JT
because this is what they do they bring
out the fishbowl and yes to pull out a
question yes your fate here what are you
good idea we had let's see let's see
knowing what she knows now what would
she tell her 20 year old self yeah man
do it in less than 30 seconds because oh
yes well you know knowing what I know
now would tell my 20 year old self this
is the process this is you're no
different than anybody else it's gonna
be okay in your 20s is a very difficult
time you're no different Jada trust and
believe is gonna be okay because I
really thought that it was it you know
you going through stuff and nobody's
tell nobody's talking to you and youth
you having problems you going through
some pain and you think something's
wrong with you you can tell my 20 year
old self that's easy all right let's see
nail polish matches your house thank you
how you keep a straight face with Will
Smith in his fun antics it's easy when
you have to deal with the 24/7 but
that's funny as the hours go by but I
mean I tell you that's one of the
blessings of having someone who's full
of so much fun and laughter all the time
is that he keeps high spirits all the
time around so that who do too I think
what you all do you your mom and your
daughter is something very special and
unlike anything that's on national TV
it's a great show thank you so much
angel has fallen opens in theaters
Friday August 23rd